[Music]
faith in humanity restored news positive
news please give me this [ __ ] when my
tank is the cuny estanque you can you
get him to do go TECA go again because I
missed those doing peekaboo but he
thinks she's hiding him happy
yes we're like where's my gun he goes
like this yes big i lo it's cute because
he's that age but if it was a grown man
doing that we'd all be like that's okay
for babies a Walmart cashier showed
amazing compassion with a nail salon
refused to serve a wheelchair-bound
woman what wow so many businesses are
involved what's your the real story
though huh exactly she was a [ __ ]
meaning because then she'd come into the
restaurant will rehearse right angle
cons cons hard piquant yeah my nails
I'll show you guys a video and I'll
explain everything for you better hereís
a [ __ ]
evany says she watched the nail salon
located just a few feet over Walmart
refused to do Angela's nails and decided
to do something about it I just wanted
to make her Day special I didn't really
want her day to be ruined
that's why I did it because unless she's
a sweetie
together the two picked out some polish
and posted up at the subway for him
posted up and I told her don't say that
I said you're fine a simple act of
patience and kindness that's still
making Angela smile we're not trying to
bash the nail salon when I try to make
them lose customers make them look mad
but maybe spread awareness that no
matter the person who they are what
color they are disability whatever
they're people - whoa she got refused
for being like disabled it seems like
they were trying to do
but then because she was moving a lot
they were like no we can't service you
so it wasn't like she rolled in in her
wheelchair and they're like Oh get away
from me you know yeah I mean like you
know that's because that's what I
pictured when I heard what I heard they
wouldn't sort of a disabled person right
I immediately thought the whole store
just record skirt like she came in can I
get my nails done and I like skirt get
out of here we serve your kind read the
sign no legs no service yeah I don't
know I just it was just we all do that
right because that's that's how the
media has a saw like pitted against each
other like that yeah you naturally think
somebody just got denied service because
they are in a wheelchair because they're
wheelchair-bound not that there's a
reasonable explanation for why they
couldn't they're like I'm scared like I
don't want to mess your hands up because
you keep moving and I can't I can't do
this like it could be that too logical
yeah reasonable well yeah because also
the way like ebony was saying that she's
not trying to - the bush yeah fashion
and nail salon because she witnessed
this whole thing so she might have seen
how that just goes to show how
conditioned I am to think everybody's
[ __ ] like prejudice because [ __ ] like
this go down and my mind wants to go
like they deserve her because she's
disabled I also love [ __ ] where it's
like this woman out of the kindness of
her heart sat her down and did this and
then called the news little called the
news man she called the news or not she
called the news yes she did she called
the news who called the news - no one
called me news so someone saw this and
wrote a post about it on social media
and that's when the news contacted that
person and that person said that evany
should receive all the appreciation she
can get because she is a good person
that's what's the matter it restored I
rescind
I feel like she did it out she didn't
call the news I think she did I the
goodness quick away that she was in the
interview though she didn't come off as
I'm trying to be famous not sure
but I like that about it for angles to
have fun this situation would be much
worse if the person that came in had a
shaky head and they want me to get LASIK
eye surgery and they're like this yeah
doctors like no I can't do that for you
but there's some other get or pursuant
to Graz like I'll fix your eyes Oh
or even imagine like somebody has
Parkinson's or something and you're
trying to like nail file or whatever you
could like injure them like that's true
I don't know man I was
what is several so it's a cerebral palsy
Assessor Eva palsy we got a guy that
gets seizures and he gets sleepy in our
karate class and sometimes in the middle
of us he just has an episode and he just
falls asleep while everyone's like oh
you have a seizure and knocked out yeah
like on the floor is he fall asleep in a
stance no like one time we were watching
people spar and then she would just like
go like this and then fall and people
are like grabbing him like holy [ __ ]
yeah what do you do I think you can do
you just did what you all watch this
happen and then it's like okay back in
the forms where they keep going but the
people around them are kind of like
grabbing him like yeah we'll be like in
the middle just just just training or
whatever and then you see him having a
little episode and were like oh [ __ ] are
you okay and then he brings back like he
comes back to consciousness or whatever
and then there's times where he's just
watching and he's sitting and then you
just hear
this guy's a pain in the ass he takes
like the MTA or whatever yeah wasn't you
this like when this person didn't tell
anybody
no maybe a few people but like it was a
shocker dude like when it went down
we were like what don't [ __ ] me fry
gonna die Jody this karate class that's
just for him it's a lot you have
somebody to help him like how does he
get from point A to point B he just
takes the train and damn dude it's it's
interesting man so they don't know they
got knocked up by hitter one of these
like walking to the train and Eve no he
doesn't do what everyone else he there's
like the basic basic stuff like he
doesn't get to do all these but it was
yeah it's just it was just the most
random thing because a lot of us were
shocked like a few of the leaders knew
what was going on but I think all of us
were like what the [ __ ] is going on
right this dude just out of nowhere just
like falls asleep this was badass no
you're still doing it yes I would like
that he's tired yeah like I didn't know
I like didn't know you're mocking this
man yeah until I found out that he had
some kind of brain thing but that's how
we are you know I'm saying yeah mocked a
disabled guy it's like dude I was like
what the [ __ ] was he fall asleep here
yeah I didn't know yeah I was like hey
you're not supposed to sleep we're
trying to do karate right now you know
they have seizures he had like four
since we snorted yeah he doesn't come to
every class I must be such a pain yeah
is there a medication that you could
take for people who are prone to
seizures Oh Ricky has medication maybe
because she said so what a boy ever
bring you guys or whatever in the human
version of it yeah I think we can
diagnose that here yeah maybe that's
what he needs all right this wild man
know I lowered her dosage for about like
maybe two years and then just recently
she had a seizure like one after there
like three in one day so I just had a
bit for her
I always feel weird because when I see
somebody with a certain ailment because
I don't know what it is out of human
curiosity I don't ask what do you have
you know yeah it's very insensitive but
it's not me trying to be insensitive I'm
just curious because I can't describe it
to somebody else and they can tell me
the only that person can yeah that I
want to ask you just because I had a
curiosity and what like life is like -
yeah like I said yeah like how did they
go through our life dude you guys know
me I'm pretty like I just ask questions
I have a question so I was talking to
this girl and and she was saying how she
has OCD and I was like oh do you have
like the we have to clean she and her
tiara like you have to arrange it and
she's like first of all like don't say
like is it one or the other cat don't
try to categorize oh my god and then she
proceeded to say but I have to be sure
everything's very clean how much I was
[ __ ] right we talking about that's
that is like how are you supposed to
know no I just asked a question
[ __ ] knowledge of it I'm not clowning
or anything I'm genuinely want to know
is it like I would have been clowning
and that she would have been rightfully
so to say that to me however you were
inquisitive yeah just ask him and this
is a person who describe themselves as a
convenient it's like they should have a
thicker skin if they're comedians so I
always think but my uncle had polio what
he still does and so as one leg is
normal and the other leg is like
extremely skinny has like no control
over what's polio isn't that some great
depression disease people don't really
get it you don't really get any more
it's a third world country kind of thing
he got bit by some sort of bug and then
like he can't really walk without a cane
and he wondered occator just innocently
know what's going on and I would just
see him walk funny all the time so I'd
make fun of him I got just coffee
he'd be walking like like he would walk
like this he has to walk like this so I
would always like make fun of them and
walk like that cuz I I didn't dolls me a
photo just copying him and one thing
that I thought was really dope like as a
kid once I found out it was a this piece
and I'm like how did you deal with polio
whatever and he goes oh and he showed me
his biceps at the time which are pretty
big and he goes you know like if I
didn't receive the lower body that I
wanted and I just built up my upper body
so I just do pull-ups every day and then
he was and the reason I became a dentist
is because since I can't be an athlete
then I work on my brain
and I'm like as dumped by like oh and
then he also said you know I cried a lot
because I could picture him to like is
this a suspenders uncle no this is
Andrews tossing and turning
no I just seem like maybe more because
he didn't have the suspenders in your
resume
I miss offenders went away I'm so used
to him now too that like any time we're
together like there's just a lifestyle
that you assume like when I see stairs I
immediately walk to him and I gave him
my farm just cuz I know if he's gonna
walk down with me interaction just
became so ingrained with part of my life
to the point where let me go somewhere
like a restaurant and we get stairs I'm
like oh yeah it's cuz my uncle's legs
all [ __ ] up that's why but then when
you grow up with it you're used to it
and you would help the producer
imitating image it as I cared that I
thought it was both of you at the time I
like three or four other this is so fun
why isn't everybody walk because like he
would walk and it's leg would swinging
his Toby that's how dumb kids are you're
when you're a kid you're just it's pure
and it's curiosity and Alexa this is
different you know what's also like it's
like wait why does he go through the
trouble of walking like that it's like
you're doing and pressuring him and
there's like hey want you to pressure me
and then you'll walk regularly yeah
that's how kids that's how kids think
yeah excuse me you could do it better if
you just did it like this yeah you you
more you said of your energy yeah it's
like duh
I just thought like the craziest gangsta
lean ever it I mean that's so tight
[Music]